the new first Minister speaking there he
has disappointed his first cabinet
cabinet that is fresh is going to take
forward a radical Progressive agenda
that I've set out throughout this
leadership contest and that I expect now
to deliver for the people of Scotland
our priorities will be in our immediate
priority will be to tackle the cost of
living crisis to make sure we continue
to invest in our public services and to
progress our well-being economy economy
and that is going to be the team that is
going to help me to deliver that a
number of new faces uh some real energy
and also a mix of experience as well in
that cabinet that I hope to happy to
take some questions
Pink Floyd she's clearly very popular
among the members as a result of the
contest shows and key is rightly popular
and she's got some great ideas and
exceptionally talented I'm sorry that
she didn't feel she was able to continue
in government but she is still a member
of this party and as her tweets showed
last night and the words that she has
put out she's 100 behind this cabinet
team she's behind me as first Minister
and Kate has got a lot to give to not
just a party for our country too
again we've still got some more
appointments of course uh to come so
obviously to look out for those but it's
important I don't believe that we are
team Hamza team K or team Ash we are
team SNP we had a group meeting
yesterday after the Parliamentary vote
and there could not have been more unity
in the party to come together for that
cause that we all believe in in the SNP
which has delivered Independence for our
country
well again I've assembled a team that
has a mix of experience some fresh faces
and new faces making the step up to
cabinet that inevitable means some
people have to move on and Keith has
given us exceptional service to not just
the government but to this country he'll
be remembered for many different roles
but particularly Injustice for really
setting their foundation for some
incredibly important reform that is
about to come and of course he has his
own mandate from the party as Deputy
leader and there's a lot of work for us
to do also within our party
the key is you probably already know and
as he has already gone out publicly too
I offered having a job I wanted him to
stay within government in the role that
he had previously but he did not want to
continue in that respect and I have many
Powers as first Minister compelling
people in government I'm afraid is not
one of them
no not in cabinet most certainly I would
say that you'll soon know the junior
ministerial appointments in due course
of course I'm disappointed because
Kate's exceptional she's a great talent
she's somebody who's got a lot to give I
would have much rather had her in
government not just government I
actually have her in in cabinet but she
told me that she didn't want to she
wanted a better time out of the
Limelight that she described it in her
own words I understand that I respect
that and she's made a a big decision uh
that's that that's for herself that's
for her family but she will continue to
serve this country continue to serve
this party with absolute distinction of
that I've got no doubt
dynamic
blackness
okay
well I just don't agree with that
assessment first of all uh we've got a
good mix of both young energetic Talent
we've also got experience energetic
talent in there as well so cabinet
secretaries like Michael Matheson like
Sean Robinson my Deputy first minister
of course Shirley and Somerville who
have been in the cabinet uh for many
many years some people returning back to
Cabinet like Angela Constance and then
some new faces stepping up to the play
as well so a really good mix in there
but this is probably the biggest
government reshuff on you'll see this
when we when we announced our Juniors I
think there's been since about 2007.
again I'm not going to give you an
exclusive as much as you would like for
the BBC in terms of my junior
ministerial appointments but you'll soon
get to hear about those in due course